honestly um i have been an emotional
roller coaster
that's kelly clarkson opening up about
the emotional roller coaster of the past
several months in an interview with
glamour uk's web series unfiltered
published on tuesday the 38 year old
singer says it's been
exhausting being a working parent during
the coronavirus pandemic
i'm still doing all the same jobs the
interview seemingly happened
prior to news breaking last week that
she filed for divorce from her husband
brandon blackstock
it's like all the things are crazy and
kelly says she's had to remind
colleagues that she's a working mom
juggling a whole lot from home
i definitely had to remind people that i
work with like look you hired a mom
and and i'm a not an absentee mom like
i'm a full-on mom so um
and i don't want to you know i already
have abandonment issues i don't want to
pass those down the voice coach
shares six-year-old river and
four-year-old remington with brandon
who is also the dad to an 18 year old
daughter savannah
and 13 year old son seth we have four
children
yes i think we're solid the talk show
host explained that her abandonment
issues are not something that she will
one day get rid of
but something that is always going to
present itself you know you get married
and you're like oh i have no one for the
dance or to walk me down the aisle you
know what i'm not going to get married
just going to lopes
kelly filed for divorce from brandon in
los angeles on june 4th
citing irreconcilable differences let it
go
live your life and do what you what you
feel is right now a source tells et
that kelly isn't ready to open up to the
world about her split
but she is ready to put herself first
and live a happier
existence you know grant and i are
hustling trying to make it happen
and i 100 percent that none of this
would be happening without my partner in
crime so
back in may kelly opened up to e.t about
how they were handling work-life balance
under quarantine
on their ranch in montana oh my husband
is now
a lighting technician an audio-visual
technician he's a director
and he's also playing cowboy on our
ranch so um
no he's got his hands full we both
definitely have our hands full um
but you know it's not just this job it's
the tv show
it's also making records like we all
still make records too it's a lot of new
things happening for us and trying to
get it done
brandon is both kelly's manager and the
executive producer of her talk show
and a source previously told et that the
two
worked together non-stop and that became
a contention
in their relationship a source close to
production on the kelly clarkson show
tells et it's unclear if he'll continue
working on the show
my family has fallen over my jobs
they're so over it
i impressed no one in my family and
another source
explained that those closest to the
couple saw this coming
quote she hasn't been happy so they are
in full support of her decision to end
her marriage
also there to support the pop star her
co-stars on the voice
gwen stefani and blake shelton quote
gwen and blake have been there for
brandon and kelly during this difficult
time
they both know how painful divorce can
be and just want the best for their
friends